hier la veuve du préfet de corse claude
erignac assassiné en février 98
s'interrogeait dans un communiqué l
agence france presse sur le remue ménage
entre policiers et juges dans l' enquête
sur cet assassinat
cette polémique agace manifestement mise
l'intérieur reportage michèle fines et
jérôme soûlard sait depuis longtemps une
rumeur c'est devenu une certitude
ces deux hommes se détestent pourtant
ils travaillent ensemble ils sont co
saisi dans l'enquêté sur l'assassinât du
préfet erignac d'un côté le très
médiatique jean louis bruguière
pionniers de l'antiterrorisme de l'autre
gilberte il un juge venue de nancy
depuis son arrivée en 1995 au sein du
pool antiterroriste l'ambiance n'est pas
au beau fixe
c'est une fuite au niveau de l' enquête
qui a tout déclenché il y a quinze jours
le canard enchaîné et l'est républicain
publie les extraits d'un rapport de
police le parquet de paris ouvre
immédiatement une information judiciaire
recel de violation du secret de
l'instruction
en clair un juge est chargé de trouver
d'où vient la fuite au sein du pool
antiterroriste l'heure est aux soupçons
la sphère revient sur la place publique
hier la famille erignac a fini par
demander dans un communiqué que les
juges ou blizzard querelle il faut que
l'on travaille ensemble se fasse
confiance et il est clair que si les
magistrats ne travaille pas main dans la
main entre d'abord puis ensuite avec les
services de police on n'aboutira jamais
je crois qu'il faut que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités chacun reprenne son
calme et la famille ne demande que cela
à la sortie du conseil des ministres ce
matin jean pierre chevènement était
aussi cette polémique est regrettable il
y a un intérêt et un seul
c'est l'intérêt de lanquais et de son
aboutissement tout le reste est
subalterne voire nuisible jean louis
bruguière gilberte il est laurence le
vert le troisième juge chargé de
l'enquêté
tous ont été entendus au palais de
justice un magistrat recherche toujours
l'auteur de la fuite